the jurogan experience when you first go
i went to so when i moved to new york i
went to boston comedy club and i barked
and handed out flyers oh did you do that
i did exactly what i did with pete
holmes his show i did exactly that show
so uh with pete he got me i moved like
five months after pete did and he was
like i'm barking at this club
and so i was like all right i'll go do
that i remember just standing on the
corner
it taught me to learn to like when i
have goals and comedy was like learn
just to have little goals like i never
said
big goals i always said just a goal that
i can get and then so
i was like i don't want to be on this
corner so i was like how do i get off
this corner
and then it was like you just want to go
stand in the door like i just
i would like at that moment dream of
just being able to take people's
tickets at the door right and so you're
like and you're just
you know hand these fires out people are
just dropping them in front of your face
like no one cares dude like just
throwing them
it's like 25 degrees out you're like
and uh uh and so but i was at boston so
chappelle used to always come by this is
2004 or five
so chappelle would always come by and do
spots he'd go up in front of
six seven people no one was there and
then we'd go outside and just say hey
chappelle's
on stage this was when chappelle show
has already been off the air
no it's it's right before he
ended it oh right before he won
wow he would come i remember him coming
and having like white makeup
on his neck like if he played like a
white person on spell show and he would
still have it on
you know because he'd come from there to
uh
straight to the stretch of the club and
so we'd go up at boston and we would
and everybody would go on stage and i'll
never forget these one people
they walked by and i said hey dave
chappelle's on stage if y'all go watch
for free
you know and boston comedy club member
had those steps and there was a window
and they go i don't believe you i was
like well i'm at a comedy club so
i was like he's in there just go look in
the window if he's not there then don't
go in
and they were like no they left
i think about those people every day
they could have watched your belt for
free
those people in that 500 bucks those 500
bucks
we bring i'm bringing them to my wife
every day and those people too
i did uh dave's show when he was in new
york uh when we did this this fear
factor episode
and tyrone bigels was on fear factor and
uh it was in a warehouse in the middle
of the winter
freezing [ __ ] cold no heat in the
warehouse so we had these little
blast furnace you know those things that
they do on sets yeah
it's like yeah those things that are
blowing hot air out and
you know you just stand in front of that
until it's time to do the scene
and then you go out there and do the
scene and everybody would run back and
stand in front of the blast furnaces
but he was in character the whole day
as tyrone bigham's
he was having so much fun yeah he was i
mean watching him
he would come by you know and he would
go up for a while
he hosted one that when uh i think it's
when boston switched to
the comedy village like he was like run
my buddy dustin chafe is the one that
got us he was running the boston
at the time and then it switched to
comedy village
whoever sold it but then chappelle came
by one night and hosted for everybody
like all the even though open mic guys
they were going up because he would come
up and just do whatever
obviously whatever he wanted and uh it
was and getting to see that bill burr
was a big deal for me
uh patrice o'neal i used to sit in
patrice's car
because he would park it out front of
the boston you couldn't park there
and he'd go on stage and i would sit in
his car and so if a cop came i would
just drive his car around and wait till
he got done
wow i went to their i saw burn patrice
where everybody's a big deal but they
were they were big for me
because when i went to new york you know
at that time 2005
something like that they're you know
birds just a comic that people know him
in new york but he's not
he's not doing he's not what he is now
obviously
and uh so they would come by and they
would run their hbo one night stands for
these 30 minutes
specials and i remember i timed
patrice's one night he didn't ask me by
the way
just like a young comic being like i'll
time it for you
and he gets off and this is i have no
concept of
being on tv i think like he has to do 30
to the dot
right and i tell him afterwards i was
like that was like 34 minutes and he
just like
looked at me and walked away
there was no reason for me i mean i was
so embarrassed about doing that
and now i know but it was like at the
time i was just trying to be
uh you know a good comic and like did
you see his uh
the comedy central documentary they did
about him i haven't watched it yet i
haven't got to watch it i haven't either
i haven't either but
i i will make myself for sure but i've
seen
so many of his sets he was the guy he
was
he was for sure one of the greats for
sure
but he was but maybe even more important
like he was a cornerstone of not
giving a [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean
like you had to have a guy like that
that was an elite stand-up comics like
what what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and you you needed a guy like that
to have a great point like really well
thought out point that was hilarious
that showed you why you shouldn't care
or why something was stupid
yeah like i remember um there was some
controversy about uh
opie and anthony and he went on some
show
and some one woman was saying that
certain jokes could never be funny
and you know and and he went and said
like a joke that was on that subject
that was funny
yeah and and then and he was like look
at all but this is a point that he had
that's like a really good point
that i stick with to this day it's like
it all comes from the same place
whether the joke is funny or the joke is
not whether it's offensive
or whether it's hilarious and
non-offensive
it's coming from the same place you're
just trying to be funny
yeah and when you're comic you
understand that because like
you'll say something that some people
might find offensive but the only reason
why you're saying it
is not because you're trying to be mean
you're saying because you think there's
some funny in there
like you're trying to find the funny and
sometimes like you'll slip
and it doesn't doesn't work at all and
sometimes agreeable is not funny
right yeah and like the whole point of
it is like i can't agree with you
exactly comedy's all built from
sometimes if someone like they'll be
like oh you're being mean to him you're
like
well i don't that's what the comedy's
mean sometimes
i mean i i told a joke where i said i
did some of my dad but i came out and i
did a show these people didn't expect a
comedy
so they didn't know i was a comedian and
i started telling my act they don't
know what i'm doing so it just sounds
like i'm doing a mean speech
because that's what comedy is if you
have no if there's no context to it
like this guy's the worst and you're
like oh but if i if i just told them
right i was the comedian they would be
like oh okay
they get it i still live to this day by
some patrice
said it was so i was uh i just kind of
started with uh
big j uh kurt metzger kurt matt's by the
way one
and kurt and big big j were one of the
comics i ever saw that i just was like
really where i was like you moved to new
york and you're like oh man
this is like the real like these guys
are like really good
you know have you been paying attention
what message is doing with uh kyle
dunnigan
yeah [ __ ] yeah matt's good is one of the
i mean one of the funniest guys i've
ever really
super smart i remember watching him uh
at the very beginning
he would take me on the road we did like
these old weird gigs and so he would
just call me his opener
and i'm like friends with kurt at this
point i drove him to the gig
and we'd be in the elevator and he's
just on the phone he's like what's that
no i'm sitting here with my opener
i'm like kurt just say my buddy
like you know like we're it's not like
i'm opening for like
you know seinfeld or something right
like it's like you're getting paid
uh 800 for this weekend dude like
he just would call me that to my face
and i got him in that room though i
could see he
we were we shared a hotel room that's
where like the gig we're doing
and he goes to put uh we're going to the
bathroom and he's like is this lotion
and i would always just like mess with
him
or if he asked a dumb question he goes i
need lotion
it says conditioner and i go that's it
it's conditioner for your skin and i
just tell him that
and then i walk in there and he's just
rubbing conditioner all over his body
and then we had to go do radio and when
he had everything he was he was
he's that's why he called me opener he's
a brilliant guy he's a rod duck
the moment i met him the first time i
met him i met him in montreal
ari introduced me to him and he goes hey
what's up and then he goes hey what are
you doing for your hair your hair's
falling out
are you doing anything for it i was like
whoa
i go yeah i'm minoxidil all kinds of
[ __ ] he's like yeah me too
literally the first words out of his
mouth man
he's just uh he's got an interesting way
of looking at things but he's also
got a a a brilliant perspective because
he grew up in a cult
yeah you know and because he grew up in
occults like
he sees a lot of those same patterns in
like woke
thinking and he's like like where you
can't question certain ideologies and he
gets really angry because no no no
i know what the [ __ ] this is because i
grew up with this [ __ ] what was he a
jehovah's witness
yeah that was what right yeah and you
know his stories about growing up as a
jehovah's witness for
[ __ ] crazy i mean can you imagine
that coming to your door
hey what do you do with your hair that's
the first thing he says you're like oh
buddy
well he's just i don't know i'm so happy
he's around though he's
yeah it makes me so happy at the comedy
store whenever i talk to him uh
uh unbelievable and when i watched him
at the very beginning
uh the patrice thing though so jay was
we used to go to patrice's house for
uh uh like fourth of july or something
he always had a party at his house
and so i got invited and jay uh and then
someone
i got into it with someone else one of
patrice's friends
basically and he was like and he told
jay hey patrice doesn't want nate to
come to the party
and uh then jay calls patrice and is
like
uh well the context of this too is like
so patrice would always ask me i grew up
in the south like i grew up you know
christian in the south typical southern
upbringing going to church all this
stuff
so patrice knew that and he would ask me
like do you believe in dinosaurs and
stuff and i would just go
with what i would say no i believe in
him but like it was
you know i was like i want to just say
no like i'm not going to give him what
he wants right because then he would
make fun of you
right right right so i would always do
that and so
then uh so jay calls him and says hey
uh our other guy says that nate can't
come to your house for that party
and patrice was like what he goes i
didn't say he goes that dude doesn't
believe in dinosaurs you don't think i
want that in my house
i want that all over my house because he
can come to the party
and i've lived my life by that with that
eye
open mindness to go if someone came up
to me say i don't believe in the moon
i'd rather talk to that guy than a guy
that does believe in the moon
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience